good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight here's an amazing story
yesterday the pentagon special
operations command made an announcement
from its official twitter account
special operations command is a very
significant thing in the u.s military
and in our country
it oversees delta force the seal teams
and the rest of our most celebrated
best-trained most
lethal war fighters so the tweet
announced that a man called richard
torres estrada is now the quote
chief of diversity and inclusion of
america's special forces and they
included his picture with the
announcement
then at the very top of its website the
special operations command included a
link
to its extensive it's quite long new
diversity and inclusion strategic
plan now the one thing we know about
that plan is that it will result in the
dramatic lowering of standards within
our elite ranks it probably already has
so how will that make america safer well
the generals never said you couldn't
find that on the website
instead they told us that quote all of
us understand that diversity and
inclusion are
operational imperatives they didn't say
how they just said their imperatives
so this is the initiative that richard
torres estrada will be running
so the question is who exactly is
richard torres estrada will his facebook
page give some indication of who he is
on it you will find an attack on the
police as racists
you'll find crude blm propaganda you
will find a photograph of donald trump
holding a bible in front of a church
next to trump is a photograph of adolf
hitler
the point is they're the same
so this is the guy who now oversees
hiring
for the navy seals if you're wondering
whether
our military leadership has gone woke
you can consider that question settled
for good
the pentagon is now the yale faculty
lounge but with cruise missiles
and that should concern you meanwhile
the rest of the world rolls on and gets
more menacing by the day tonight for
example the suez canal one of the
busiest shipping lanes in the world
is blocked by a stranded container ship
was it an
accident maybe maybe not we don't know
what we do know is that the suez canal
is vital
to the world's economy that's not an
overstatement the suez canal is one of
only about a dozen strategic choke
points that control virtually all global
trade and now it's closed
so this is a challenge to america's
critical national interests how is the
pentagon responding to that
well they're occupied with other things
right now for the last month the entire
u.s military has been operating under a
so-called stand down order
that was issued by the new secretary of
defense lloyd austin
the defense contractor now running the
military lloyd austin believes the real
threat to america is not the chinese
government or
paralyzed global trade the real threat
to this country is people who didn't
vote for joe biden
watch and if confirmed i will fight hard
to stamp out sexual assault
and to rid our ranks of racist and
extremists
the job of the department of defense is
to keep america safe from our enemies
but we can't do that if some of those
enemies lie within our own ranks
so republicans voted to confirm him he
is himself an extremist
and they have said virtually nothing
about lloyd austin since because they're
paralyzed they're paralyzed because
lloyd austin has no problem calling his
opponents racist immediately
ridding our ranks of racists and
extremists
the key question is how does lloyd
austin define a racist
or an extremist the definition matters
this show has been denounced as a
dangerous white supremacist organ
for the crime of reading martin luther
king quotes on the year so it's worth
finding out what those words mean
but lloyd austin doesn't provide a
definition and that's not accidental
because what you're seeing is not an
attempt to make the military better
what you're seeing is a political purge
of the military
consider what has been happening during
the military's training on quote
extremism
a lot of enlisted soldiers have asked a
pretty basic question
hey wait a minute weren't the blm and
antifa
rioters this summer extremists seems
like they were they murdered people they
murdered a lot more people than died at
the capitol on january 6th
a lot more they burn businesses they
wrecked cities in some places
it took the national guard to stop them
so why aren't these people quote
extremists
hmm good question well a man called
ramon colon lopez was called in to
explain why to tell the troops why they
were wrong
colon lopez is the senior insist
enlisted adviser to the chairman of the
joint chiefs of staff
these questions he conceded are quote
coming from every echelon that we're
talking to
some people may think all right so the
events of 6th of january happened how
come you're not looking at the situation
that was going on in seattle prior to
that
well yeah exactly kind of an obvious
question
well ramon colon lopez has an answer
actually it's more of a threat
quote i am concerned about the way that
some people are looking at the current
environment
and what they are thinking they can do
and act upon based upon their personal
beliefs
oh in other words if you ask questions
like these obvious questions
you are by definition dangerous clone
lopez said he was working hard to quote
make sure that military members
understand the difference between
seattle and washington dc all right what
are those differences exactly
well here's one blm clone lopez
explained
is a quote social injustice organization
and therefore it's not extreme also
quote when the military called upon us
to go ahead and support an effort in
washington
we did we never got called for the law
enforcement issue that was happening in
seattle
oh so the mayor of seattle never called
the national guard to put down antifa
therefore antifa is not an extremist
organization
well that's ludicrous obviously in fact
it's not even true
actually the national guard did deploy
to seattle during the riots last summer
but whatever
colon lopez's job isn't to make sense
it's to send a political message from
the joe biden administration
we're in charge now this week we spoke
to a dea agent who was fired for being
in washington on january 6th
he didn't riot he never even went into
the capitol building in fact he defended
the cops
outside against the writers he's on
video doing that but it didn't matter
he didn't vote for joe biden so he's
gone and he's hardly alone
earlier this month the fbi arrested a
man from oklahoma called anthony alfred
griffith
according to the fbi here's anthony
alfred griffith's crime he walked into
the capitol building through
open doors and took pictures then he
handed those pictures to federal
investigators
here's the fbi's criminal complaint
against griffith accuses him quote
of witnessing multiple people trying to
break down a door
oh he saw it happen so for the crime of
witnessing
other people of trying to break down a
door anthony alfred griffith now faces
seven years in prison but don't worry
people like anthony alfred griffith our
leaders tell us are extremists they're
white supremacists
and our military needs to be laser
focused on making certain
that no one who votes like these people
do can
ever serve in the armed forces again
we absolutely need to look at uh
any type of white supremacists that are
still members of the military and how
they're being targeted for recruitment
by white supremacist groups and we need
to weed this out this whole idea of a
police
officer on police officer violence with
those officers who have been
turned by white extremists is really
scary to me and i know it's got to be
scary for the other police officers
i am considering legislation to create a
stand-alone
a punitive article in the uniform court
of military justice to it
to address violent extremism in the
ranks
and to send a message of deterrence that
this kind of conduct will not be
tolerated in the military
we've seen a lot of reports highlighting
how many of the attackers were
veterans and there's been really a
growing recognition that
the military has to do more to address
extremism in its ranks
it's really an amazing clip the first
two people you saw speaking
hirono and duckworth are extremists
they're the most extreme members of the
u.s senate they went on television this
week to tell us that people with the
wrong skin color couldn't be hired for
federal
jobs did anyone at the capitol on
january 6 call for that
not one person that we're aware of and
we denounce it immediately so they're
extremists by definition
and they're lecturing us about extremism
the military has to do more to address
extremism
and in a way they're doing that by
aggressively promoting extremism
every two months senior enlisted leaders
in the military gather for something
called the commanding general
stewardship of the army profession forum
in january that forum included a quote
professional dialogue on the racist hate
tract
white fragility written by lunatic robin
d'angelo
no one condemned robin deangelo's
obvious extremism
they celebrated it just last month
someone called lieutenant general brad
webb
the commander of the air force education
and training command made it very
explicit
he acknowledged that the air force was
recruiting candidates with a private
pilot's license now that might seem like
a wise course
flying planes is what the air force does
but to lieutenant general brad webb
no that's systemic racism
one of the other areas in line with that
has been
aptitude tests yes and in fact the chief
mentioned that one as well
uh in his talk the other day uh but we
are
deep uh uh underway in uh
updating uh pilot tests and also officer
qualification tests
that that at its root you know you you
get
uh you get a weighted score if you have
a private pilot's license well that's a
socio-economic
uh influencer in other words if you're
rich enough to afford to have
private pilot time you can get a license
that ought not be
you know weighted right in such a way
that you exclude
uh you know you know various uh
ethnic groups so the real question is
how did a doughy [ __ ] like that end up
with an important job of the military
this isn't the department of
transportation that's not the dmv this
is a serious thing
this is the federal agency to which we
give the most money
that exists to protect the rest of us
from foreign threats and guys like that
have power
that guy's the commander of air force
education
and it's not just him in october the
head of the air force recruiting
office major general ed thomas published
a piece on yahoo
called 86 of air force pilots are white
men
here's why that needs to change
so you read this and you've got to
wonder with the families of the
thousands of american
white pilots who have died defending
this country over the last hundred years
thought of that
ed thomas wants them so that their
husbands and fathers and sons should
have been flying planes in the first
place because they were the wrong color
pretty remarkable we actually called ed
thomas after his piece came out to ask
about this he was kind enough to talk to
us
had a long conversation he never
explained the only thing that matters
how his race mongering makes this
country safer he obviously didn't care
clearly hadn't even thought about it how
did someone like that get power in the
u.s military there are a lot of generals
like that
well matt gates represents thousands of
military personnel these are people who
join the services because they love the
country and they want to protect it
these are the people who are getting
crushed by this stuff in the u.s
military the enlisted people and no
one's speaking up for them
right now so at a hearing in congress
the other day matt gates did
how long until make america great again
hats are considered an extremist symbol
how long until catholic or pro-life
groups or those who believe in two
genders
are too extreme for the ruling
woktopians
today is about nothing more than cancel
culture
coming for our military and it is
disgusting
disgusting he said well disgusting is
usually hyperbole
but in this case it's understatement now